right with my new book triumph and so
it's the third book in my dr.
blood-bought series it's the doctor
blood books is like this retro science
fiction universe that I created a few
years back and I've been writing sort of
stories for it and building the universe
over the last sort of six or seven years
since we first brought it to comic-con
and yeah and this is the latest book
which I've really focused on this guy
lord coxswain who's kind of an idiot in
space he's a buffoon is more on these
racist he's a homophobe is a beast is
it's not a heroic story but it is sort
of a classic adventure in space but with
a it's basically that the
kid is Amanda space I kind of think
about well the idea is that it's so it's
sitting in the sort of 20s or 30s in an
alternate universe in the
science-fiction of that era so in that
era you know we weren't sure what would
be on the moon we thought Venus would
have jungles and Planet and flora and
fauna and we thought you know Mars would
have the canals and have maybe other
civilization all that stuff was
speculated upon so expecting our science
fiction was our local backyard you know
the solar system and so include what's
it's the same so but here the British
Empire has gone into space first and
it's connell are colonizing Venus so
taking over and you know cross bringing
Church of England and cricket and
everything else to to the godless
heathens of Venus and sorting them out
so and the only thing the Venetians
aren't the bad guys in it although he
ends up shooting a lot of them they're
just the they're basically just the
people who are unlucky enough to be 200
years behind technologically when when
England turned up and they're off it's
kind of started in a way a back-to-front
way I started designing all these ray
guns and I did the most paintings from
my wall and I talked to Richard about -
about the Richard Taylor who runs with a
workshop and he was kind of searching
for ideas for collectables we could do
and so I thought well you know maybe we
could do these ray guns and as soon as
he was into the idea and we're starting
to make them I thought okay well maybe I
should make the comic book and Richard
said yeah go for it so I started telling
telling the story of the backstory of
the world and even did that know better
the back-to-front way I didn't tell the
story of a character like Lord coxswain
I made a catalog of ray guns and
adventure
and I told the sort of backstory about
what doctor Robert says and dr. Roberts
itself this isn't doctor good but this
is more cotton but dr. Boyd Boyd is
basically their Halliburton of the of
the 1920s basically this massive
multinational company corporation that
makes Reagan's Rockets 40 old children
shoes anything and sells it anywhere but
dr. Godward himself is like this sort of
malevolent businessman he's a sociopath
as well except he's actually the bad guy
in the whole story I suppose and he it's
in his interest to make sure that it's
war between the Earth and Venus and that
we colonized Venus is also an his
ethnicity arm the other side and and so
I wanted to I told the back story from
that kind of point of view like writing
the advertising about the world and sort
of trickling that stuff in there
collectibles are a Twitter in z.com
which is like our main website and this
is up to roblox website but since no one
can pronounce dr. broad bots I work or
endlessly
but yeah it's a our website has all the
collectables and his art prints and
almost